ROGERS PLACE.
>> JAY WOODCROFT WANTS TO START
ERASED IN THE CORNER BY THE  SEN
THAT SHORT PASS NOT
SEEN THE SECOND UNIT EMPLOYED
FAR MORE BY BY
BACKSTROM THAT KOSKINEN
>> Louie: NOT TOO MANY HE'KOSKI.
McLEOD TO DRAISAITL. OUT!
HERE'S NURSE.ROKES ACROSS ICE.
AND JUST FOLLOW THE BOUNCING
PUCK.
THIS ONEOUT.
RIGHT AGAIN, THE WASHINGTON
CAPITALS GO ON THE POWER PLAY.
BACK TO THE BLUE LINE.
PUT A LITTLE STRIKEETSOV.
CARLSON SHOT.
THAT STAYED OUT.AME
YOU BETTER BE SURE.
BACKSTROM WAS THE ONE ALL THE
LOOKS UP.
BANKS ONE OFF THE BOARDS PICKED
OFF BY CECI.
IN TRANSITION I I RIGHT THERE,
THE BACKHAND SIDE.
THE SMILE SAID IT ALL AFTER
WORKED OVER BY HATHAWAY.
BUT EDMONTON HAS THAT SHOOTING
MENTALITY.
SAMSMS BY
NECESSITY.
>> Jack: LEAD PASS.
OSHIE STREAKS IN AND SCORES
THIS IS GOING TO COUNT THOUGH
AND THIS IS THE BREAKOUT CARLSON
.
GETS THAT SHOT THROUGH DARNELL
BACKSTROM.
KUZNETSOV.
WAITING! KEPT THIS PLAY IN MOTI.
IT GOES TO CARLSONK AND LOUIE Y
THE WAY.GRABS.
>> Jack: FOURTH TIME THE CAPSNE.
MET BY A SHOT.
HE
COUGHED IT UP.
TWO-ON-ONE.
DRAISAITL AND McDAVID.
McDAVID SHOOTS SCORES!!